breaking news this wednesday night
president trump is impeached a second
time
he must go he is a clear and present
danger
the republicans who turned their backs
on him there's no way i could vote no on
this
plus security concerns for joe biden's
inauguration
the confusion over ontario's new
stay-at-home order i can't stay inside
all day long
what's permitted what's prohibited and
what's still not clear
from keeping cases down to a virtual
lockdown why ireland is no longer
crushing the curve
plus a penalty of the pandemic i can't
really foresee myself
getting painted up to sit in my basement
by myself is excitement on ice for the
new nhl season
global national with donna friesen
those in favor say aye
those the poles say no in the opinion of
the chair of the
eyes have it this is the moment
president donald trump was impeached for
a second time the american house of
representatives charging him with
incitement of insurrection
he is the only american president in
history to suffer this fate
good evening and thanks for joining us
one week after an angry mob of trump
supporters
attempted to disrupt the peaceful
transfer of power in america
lawmakers held president trump to
account those insurrectionists were not
patriots
they were not part of a political base
to be catered to unmanaged
they were domestic terrorists and
justice
must prevail but they did not appear out
of a vacuum
they were sent here sent here by the
president
with words such as a cry to fight like
hell
all democrats in the house voted to
impeach and this time they were joined
by 10 republicans who for
the first time turned their backs on
trump
i'm afraid patriots of this country have
died in vain i'm afraid my children
won't grow up in a free country
i'm afraid injustice will prevail but
truth
truth sets us free from fear my vote to
impeach our sitting president is not a
fear-based decision
i am not choosing a side i'm choosing
truth it's the only way to defeat fear
this vote to impeach is similar to a
criminal charge the next step is a trial
in the senate
if convicted there president trump would
never be able to hold public office
again
it looks likely that won't happen until
after his term
ends in one week our jackson proskow is
watching history unfold tonight
jackson well donna no matter how this
ends for donald trump in the senate he
will not be able to erase the stain of a
double impeachment from his record
and this second history-making
impeachment comes as his entire
political empire is crashing down
in a scene reminiscent of the american
civil war armed soldiers are posted
inside the u.s capitol to defend against
a domestic
threat the eyes are 232
the nays are 197. while members of
congress carried out an unprecedented
second
impeachment of a sitting president
donald trump is a living
breathing impeachable offense he must
not remain in power one moment longer
not one moment longer the dangerous too
great
we must impeach this time the effort to
remove trump has bipartisan support
i will vote yes on these articles of
impeachment
even trump's most loyal allies who
object to impeachment
admit he must still wear the charge of
inciting violence against the government
of the united states
you'll never take back our country with
weakness
for his words in the weeks and hours
before the capitol was
stormed the president bears
responsibility for wednesday's attack on
congress by mob rioters
he should have immediately denounced the
mob when he saw what was unfolding
those who did object insist the process
was both rushed and
needless just a week before trump leaves
office well
so what that's called politics
if we impeached every politician who
gave a fiery speech to a crowd of
partisans
this capital would be deserted
democrats believe trump poses a danger
given the ongoing threat of domestic
extremism by his supporters
threats that could disrupt the
inauguration of joe biden and we know
that the president of the united states
incited this insurrection
this armed rebellion against our common
country
with the house voting to impeach trump's
fate rests with the senate
where the highest ranking republican
mitch mcconnell has said he has not made
a final decision on whether to remove
trump from office
the matter may not be taken up until
after biden's inauguration
solely to keep trump from running again
tonight trump finds himself increasingly
alone and
isolated in his final days in the white
house corporate donors are fleeing
business opportunities for the trump
organization are drying up
and that threat to bring it to the
senate could also bring in an abrupt end
to trump's future political plans donna
because
the big picture plan here is to keep
trump from running again in 2024 and
hanging over the republican party after
he's gone
in jackson president trump has said
impeaching him will lead to more anger
joe biden and his team were briefed
today by the fbi and secret service
about the threat picture for the
inauguration on wednesday
give us a sense of the security level
this is really alarming stuff the 20 000
members of the national guard who are
being brought into washington dc are
being told to prepare for things like
improvised explosive devices in the
crowd and in and around the city after
those two bombs were found
one week ago during the ride on capitol
hill we're also told they're being told
to prepare for things like mass casualty
events
which is why the biden harris
administration is stressing the need to
get a better picture
of the security challenges they're going
to inherit on day one
because donna is clear the threat of
domestic extremism will not simply
vanish with biden's inauguration
it will not jackson prosko in washington
tonight thanks
late today president trump put out a
video statement on the white house
government twitter account his own
account has been removed
mob violence goes against everything i
believe in
and everything our movement stands for
no true supporter of mine could ever
endorse
political violence it is too late of
course for a growing list of businesses
which are cutting ties with trump and
his family including deutsche bank which
has been
his biggest lender and today new york
city dumped trump mayor bill de blasio
announced the city will be severing all
contracts with the trump organization
he says new york can break the deals if
the vendor's leadership is engaged in
criminal activity
the trump organization operates a
carousel and skating rinks in central
park
and a golf course in the bronx the deals
are worth about 17 million dollars u.s
a year the political upheaval in
washington is having no impact on the
pandemic which is still raging
across the u.s yesterday the u.s set a
staggering new record for covid 19
deaths
in just 24 hours more than 4 300
people died the virus has now killed
nearly 400 000
americans canada is faring better but
the situation is increasingly worrying
here too
more than 6 800 new cases have been
reported across canada today
more than 150 more canadians have died
most of the new infections are in
ontario and quebec
but the impacts of the virus are
widespread here's the map of canada
adjusted for population
right now saskatchewan has the most
active cases per capita
319 infections per 100 000 people
the next hardest hit is alberta followed
by quebec and then ontario ontario's
premier says his stay-at-home order
which comes into effect at midnight
is crystal clear but that is not how a
lot of ontarians see it
there are complaints it is anything but
clear about what people are allowed to
do
or how the rules will be enforced our
abigail beeman went looking for some
answers
ready to get out to get fresh air and
the province of ontario says
under the new stay at home order you can
get outside
ish you must i'm going to repeat that
stay home
it's the law and it will be enforced but
there were so many
questions about what exactly is allowed
after tuesday's announcement the
premier's office had to issue this
faq list for journalists wednesday
morning trying to tackle what's an
essential item
trip and work but in each case ontario
cannot determine all the answers as
every ontarian has
unique circumstances and regional
considerations
we need everyone to use their best
judgment we pushed the province on one
big question
enforcement especially around outdoor
exercise
can you get a ticket for being outdoors
in a park or
at a skating rink your household may
have fewer than the five person limit
but what if other people show up too
a government official told global news
bigger groups would
break the rules but enforcement is up to
local officers
and said we should direct all questions
to them we are still unclear i can tell
you that
other law enforcement entities
provincially and
regionally and municipally are looking
for
clear direction from the province
neither toronto nor ottawa could lay out
a plan for parks
rinks and toboggan hills we have asked
the province for greater clarity around
a number of aspects and i hear some
elected officials
local ones and other ones oh it's
confused folks
there is no confusion here it's very
simple
stay home given the bleak nature of our
restrictions and what's going on today
giving people the ability to exercise
and be outdoors
is probably a human right we should
probably be
prescribing given that it's not a
particular risk
we end up burning the public's trust and
the public's energy
health experts believe getting outside
safely is important
dr stephen burrell provides clinical
care to toronto's homeless population
he's particularly worried about the
inequity that persists
not everyone has a backyard in which to
isolate
i was reflecting on our experience back
in march of last year when we had
one client who came to us with an 800
ticket for sitting in a bench
he wants the focus to be on support
rather than
enforcement abigail beeman global news
ottawa late today the ontario government
did release the
formal stay-at-home order it's four
pages long it contains 29
exceptions to the rule including going
to work going to the bank going to the
airport to travel to another province
and walking the dog in some long-term
care homes in this country the promises
to protect residents are being broken
today ontario hit a grim
milestone more than 3 000 residents in
long-term care homes there have now died
in this pandemic
40 percent of homes have active
outbreaks right now
vermont's premier ford has promised he'd
do everything he can to stop it
so what went wrong michael couture is
looking into that
if if that's that's required in my
opinion
some homes are it's required for a
moment it seemed ontario premier doug
ford was again
preparing to send canadian troops to
help the dire situation
in long-term care homes saying he was
offered the help
by prime minister justin trudeau just an
hour earlier
so i'll take them up on that offer but i
just want to make sure
once they come where they're going and
where we're needed most
but in a statement the premier's office
tried to walk that back
suggesting the military isn't needed
right now saying quote
we will continue to work with the
federal government and if any further
support is needed
we will request it the confusion doesn't
take away from the serious problem
facing long-term care homes in ontario
249 homes or about 40 percent of
facilities
have coveted 19 outbreaks and geriatric
specialists are criticizing ford's claim
that he was going to put an iron ring
around long-term care centers
to protect them from the virus many of
us are saying it seems like it's more of
an iron sieve
because the staffing plans that bc for
example in quebec did
where they hired thousands of new
workers and made sure that they could be
on the front lines ready to go when the
second wave has actually
done a lot of good some jurisdictions
prevented personal support workers from
working at multiple homes
to help stop the spread while quebec
increased salaries and paid for training
to attract more employees but that
hasn't happened in ontario
she's 82 before covet
she was very alert jessica wong's
grandmother
caught the coronavirus at the tender
care home in toronto
and she wonders why more wasn't done in
the second wave
to keep the virus out if there's no
visitation
and none of the residents are leaving
the home then it's
brought in by staff ford acknowledged
that saying security guards are going to
homes to do checks
to make sure every person that comes in
gets checked
to make sure it's documented when they
were tested
when was the last time they got tested
the ontario government hopes by doing
that
and ramping up vaccinations in long-term
care homes
will put an end to the out-of-control
outbreaks
mike lacouter global news ottawa
more help is on the way for canada's
indigenous communities dealing with
covid19
the federal government is spending 1.2
billion dollars for more ppe
staffing and other support to help slow
the spread of the virus
according to canada's public health
agency there are now more than 4 300
active cases on first nations across the
country and numbers are rising fast
last weekend more than 800 people living
on reserves tested positive
for the virus these numbers
continue to be alarming and have now
exceeded the national average
and will continue to do so if gone
unchecked
the indigenous services minister says
he's encouraged by progress in getting
vaccines to remote and indigenous
communities but he says
logistics are complicated and the
rollout will take time
he's urging people to keep following
public health orders
air canada is slashing more than a
thousand jobs the airline is blaming
increased federal
travel restrictions and quarantine
requirements air canada says the
measures have had an immediate impact on
bookings and led to a 25 percent
scale down in operations about 1700 jobs
will be cut
200 employees at its express carriers
will also be impacted
air canada began cutting routes on
december 8. this week the airline
revealed it will stop flying into new
brunswick's capital
and to two communities in newfoundland
and labrador
an investigation is underway tonight in
montreal after one of that city's
largest synagogues was vandalized
a warning some may find the image
disturbing
mp mark miller tweeted this photo
showing the anti-semitic symbols painted
on the doors of the synagogue
a letter sent to the congregation says
the graffiti has now been
removed and a man is in custody he's
expected to appear in court
tomorrow from success to a surge in
covet 19 cases
coming up why ireland is now struggling
to contain
the coronavirus
back in early december ireland had one
of the lowest rates of covet 19 in
europe but that has changed
rapidly it now has one of the highest
rates per capita in the world
since the new year around 1 in 70 people
in ireland have tested positive for the
virus and today
the country announced 63 new deaths its
highest
daily death toll since april experts say
the main reason for the surge is not the
new more contagious
variant of the virus that emerged in
nearby britain
it is human behavior redmond shannon
explains
ireland is almost in full lockdown the
most
stringent measures since last spring the
country has been blindsided by a recent
spike
in covet cases we're seeing deaths
rising
in a way that actually not only
equals our situation back in march and
april but actually exceeds that and
that's really really shocked all of us
shocking because ireland had been doing
relatively well in early december
ireland's case rate per capita was a
fraction of canada's
but through christmas and past new years
it has shot up to become among the
highest in the world
part of the problem may have been
ireland comparing its performance to
other european nations most of which had
very high infection rates
unfortunately i believe we we didn't get
the figures down
adequately in early december but then
there was a lot of expectation
and almost political pressure on the
government from retailers and from
the hospitality industry to open up and
have some sort of save christmas if you
like
faithfully the government decided to
allow limited christmas socializing
the irish love christmas is the main
reason here i guess and
and with the best wood in the world that
we're gonna there's gonna be households
mixing anyway
and it looks like as if that was far too
extensive in a sense and
one example was they were trying to
restrict families mixing so two families
were allowed
people clearly broke that rule had more
than more than three or four households
mixing over successive days
the new more infectious variant is now
more prevalent
potentially brought in by immigrants
from the uk coming home
for the holidays it might be part of the
story but the main reason as i say is
behavioral change
but it is there and it's spreading so
it's even more important
to restrict movements and so on like
canada ireland has just introduced the
requirement for a negative test result
for
all arriving air passengers that move
and ireland's overall strategy is
compromised by its open border with
northern ireland
its rules more closely aligned with
measures in great britain
redmond shannon double news london
still ahead ice jams build up flood
fears in bc
an unpredictable situation is developing
in northern bc
ice jams on the nachaco river are
threatening to flood low-lying areas
around
vanderhoof a small community west of
prince george
four and a half thousand people who live
there have been told to exercise extreme
caution
the ice is causing the river to
fluctuate about a meter overnight and
temperatures shifting above and below
freezing means the ice jams can release
without any warning we now have a better
idea how
smoke from wildfires impacts air quality
in the u.s
according to a new study by researchers
at stanford university and uc
san diego wildfire smoke now counts for
up to half of all fine particulate
pollution
in the western united states and 25
nationwide
the concentration of those tiny
pollutants roughly
doubled between 2006 and 2008.
researchers say the warming climate and
decades of fire suppression are driving
the wildfire smoke
a polish zoo is celebrating the first
birth of a rare
rhinoceros at one week old this indian
rhino is still learning how to walk
the unnamed female calf is now one of
172
captain zoos around the world about
three thousand of them remain
in the wild the birth is a big victory
zoos
fight to save the endangered species
if a hockey puck drops with no fans
around does play
go on next the nhl starts a strange
season
hockey fans have something to look
forward to nhl hockey returns tonight
the league is focused on keeping the
game alive and players and staff safe
from cobit 19
but there are already some problems
before the first puck is even dropped
mike drollet reports there's so much
that doesn't make sense about today
for one opening night in the nhl has
never been in january
and when montreal plays toronto there's
an unmistakable buzz in the city that is
just
not there it seems pretty bleak out here
it's just like january gray
if there's anybody who can add some
color to the situation it's the leaf
super fan known as
dark guy he made a name for himself well
you can see why
and while he has an amazing ability to
get the crowd riled up
until the pandemic is over he'll be in
his sports cave
at home alone and make up free well i
thought
that question brought up to me a couple
times uh and it's just like i can't
really foresee myself
getting painted up to sit in my basement
by myself it's a bit of a bummer but
he's hoping a little hockey will lighten
the mood
especially in ontario where a state of
emergency is in effect
although that could potentially backfire
on the league one of my friends actually
had a pretty like clever joke it's just
like yeah no gatherings of
more than five unless you're in the nhl
and yes covet has already had an impact
with 27 players testing positive
including 17 from the dallas stars so
the nhl is skating on thin ice
before the first game is even played i
probably
would would put finishing the season at
a 50 50
chance oh boy not a lot of positivity
there
well how about this any hockey fan will
smile at the thought of the pond hockey
games planned for lake tahoe
not on lake tahoe like some players
thought i have never
uh skated on a lake my entire life we're
playing on the 18th uh
fairway bro no i didn't even know
for real oh just crushed my dreams in
2021 the dream is simple
play the games award the stanley cup and
give us reason to cheer again
mike rowlett global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen
tonight we leave you with a tribute to
one of canada's greatest
rowers kathleen heddle who has been
called the mozart of her era
has died of cancer at the age of 55. the
two-time olympian from trail bc rode her
way to three
gold medals thanks for watching take
care of yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
bye-bye